I have never funded anything with UFO
reverse engineering I don't have any
plans to I don't care about that I I'm
into this because of the nature of
reality and just pure intellectual
genuine curiosity and if there were
opportunities to sort of work on this
stuff and through through P patronage or
directly yeah I'd say yeah like I
think it'd be awesome to work on so I'm
I'm I'm with you except for that so I am
interested in this from an intellectual
side and what this has to do with
reality yeah but I would not work on it
that's fair and I don't want to be told
any secrets so sometimes people will say
like have has this guest talked to you
off air I always tell people don't share
with me anything that you wouldn't be
willing to publicly say yeah